you've never had coffee in your life
the time I had coffee had to force
myself to drink it you had coffee once
in your life yeah to stay up yeah I've
never been to Starbucks
oh yeah I've been to Starbucks and I
picked out a bagel number
cream cheese all right guys this is the
first time you've ever tried coffee
correct black coffee this is straight
coffee with that being said cheers and
you should take a good drink though
right
that's what I'm saying I have to see how
hot it is
you know what that tastes like guys
mortgage bills stress a lot of [__]
kids in the house I just need to get
through my [__] day so drink some
shitty coffee this is actually terrible
it's a